hello everyone and welcome back to
roller coaster tycoon 1 today I am going
to do something with this area I just
don't quite know what because that all
depends on the rides that I get from my
research and development department and
so far it hasn't been too thrilling and
I said that because I'm investigating
the thrill rides I mean [ __ ] terrible
I'm sorry so I need to come up with
something else to do and in the meantime
that'll be constructing a new roller
coaster I haven't even really thought
this out too much but no I could do
something like that but I could also
build a suspended roller coaster
although I'm not really a big fan of
those things I feel like I would want to
have a something over here I think the
idea was that I could potentially build
a roller coaster via you know what I am
just going to try to build a wooden
roller coaster over here even though I'm
not too much of a fan of these things
I'm just going to try that
ok so we're already running into
problems we've got these this little
hill over here which I do kind of need
to get rid of let's see you know I think
I could just at the low ceiling like
that oh why why why does the
terraforming never do what you wanted to
do ok small little just a a small one
[Music]
I don't know I don't know if this is
exactly what I want
this does not even look good I don't
think it does you know what I could also
do I can go down potentially over here
and do some cool stuff over there that
is not possible sadly however anything
is possible when your man smells like
old spice and not a lady so I'm just
going to try that and that works so
that's good and I I kind of want to have
the lift Hill all the way at the end of
the park border over here because that
that way you can actually see the rest
of the layout and it's not completely
obstructed by the lift so if you look at
it from this perspective so we're gonna
have to go up as one important aspect of
a lift hill and then we're gonna do some
sketchy stuff over here first though I I
am going to change the color scheme
because this is extremely terrible and
this is definitely not the kind of color
that I want
I don't know wooden roller coasters
always seem to start off with this this
weird dark brownish color but I have
never really liked that color
I do like this color though a lot so
that's cool I don't know if that is
really high enough for what I want I
could also go a bit higher than that and
do like like this cool element over here
which I don't have the money for yet but
now I do and let's see if this looks
good
definitely not like that it's gonna have
to be a steep slope and doesn't work
though hmm and yeah the problem that you
get then is that it doesn't look that
great from this angle but I'm still
going to try it I'm going to lower it
just a tiny bit because this is somewhat
out of place and to build it like that
and I think we're good to go with this
now the next thing I want to try is I
don't want to go up right away after
this because no that would seem like a
stupid thing to do actually you know
what I'm going to make that curve a bit
smaller because it was kind of big right
there and then we're gonna go down which
is impossible that's a shame and in that
case I'm just going to do like that
there we go and then we're gonna have to
do that cool little element over there
and go up again I suppose no that that
still doesn't really make too much sense
hmm and this is definitely not the kind
of layout that a wind roller coaster
usually Hans I wish I could actually
have the drop right off to that nut
place over there but I can't my too much
land over there so I'm going to have to
be careful with that but you know what
I'm I'm just going to try it let's just
see how far I can get with this um only
two down which is a bummer and then
we're just gonna buy more land there we
go
and I guess I can always I can also bind
the line over there so plenty of land
and let's see if this works you know
this this is a pretty cool element but
it almost looks like it's way too high
and yeah it's on it's on 22 that there
is no there's no possibility of doing
that the only thing I could do against
that is actually add another one of
these but then I don't think I have the
available space over here it's actually
built that other element which I just
don't oh got that and that kind of sucks
to be honest you know what I'm just
going to bend the rules at this point
I'm just going to make a little pit in
the ground and work it in there okay
thank you very much
and going to do like that I hope this is
not too cheap but I really want to have
this kind of element and then we're
gonna remove the trees it's not like we
haven't done enough for a station at
this point yet because we're building a
wooden roller coaster so whatever now
the issue with this element though is
how do you actually make it look good
because that I don't know about this
actually mm-hmm that is definitely
terrible but I don't know if this would
actually work it is kind of odd isn't it
like it looks okay from some angles
especially this one it looks really good
for him over here but it just doesn't
really do the trick and aside from
actually not being possible over here
hmm I feel like I am actually running
out of options over here and doing that
first drop over there was perhaps not
the best idea mmm yeah let's just let's
try that again because it might just
work have you tried the second time what
do I always do that I seriously always
do that oh wait that is not even that
bad that was actually pretty cool and
then we move like from that we move over
here I suppose now it's kind of weird
but I do have an idea that I could
actually do some fun stuff with this so
I'm going to try this no I'm gonna had a
small airtime Hill over here and by that
I mean a ridiculously fast and pretty
big airtime Hill
scrapland I'm going to make it even
bigger no we go it's not even an airtime
Hill anymore it's just a regular Hill
and we can't do that sadly so I'm just
going to dig into the ground once again
why is that not it's possible not okay
thank you now we're gonna have to place
this over here and do that and remove
the tree I'm going to smooth this at
some point
of course because this is definitely a
site I cannot stand but first I need to
work my way out of this mm-hmm
might actually be better to just do this
same thing but that is that is a bit
high isn't it because how high do ya was
18 over there 18 over there so he
definitely can't do another 18 meters
height the thingy well I'm just going to
do that standard kind of curve thing
over here not enough money what is this
no one's going to raise the money the
loans that is and guests want more to
eat well I'm going to give them more to
eat pizza should be plenty where's this
pizza going to be though I feel like
this would actually be your cool area
just because there's nothing else and of
course some benches next to it oh oh no
well in that case I'm just going to call
it pizza
and give to half-lit have been next to
that and more little bins and benches
okay
now we should be good to go let's
continue work on the roller coaster yeah
so far I kind of like it but this curve
is and is kind of an issue here you know
what I could also do I could just move
it around the little like that though
that does not work like that then
another tile and there we go but know
that that definitely does not look good
you know what I'm just going to do the
simple thing I think I'm just going to
do like this and then that this is kind
of the basic shape that once again like
to helix kind of things and then have
some cool Hills in that and stuff
however that airtime Hill seems
incredibly small I don't know if that is
actually healthy so nice if I can do
something else with that mmm I could
just add a diagonal section over here
and by that I mean just one tile further
and of course there's trees in the way
again
yeah that is one thing of course it's
just a nit picky thing and it got fixed
in the later versions of the game but
I'm not always too happy about the fact
that it doesn't automatically remove
trees or this when you click on the
supports and then it wants to edit that
section in you're like no I don't want
to edit that section
and I definitely don't want that okay
what if I do this and that doesn't work
but I have an idea
and a splendid one about I am going to
make this hill even higher yes because I
don't want the rock oceans to go too
fast
now I'm going to add this curve and then
over here we're gonna go up now that is
possible so and then over here we're
gonna add that thingy which does not
work at all
Oh hmm yeah well that was my idea but
that didn't entirely work okay so I'm
going to try to make a bit bigger and
see if I can do anything with that nope
in that case I'm going to make it even
bigger and still can't do anything with
that is a bummer and I'm pretty sure and
this is not possible however this is
this might this might just work
hold on I mean let me get that piece is
there still ok it's that one
Oh with it there's another tree or is it
the park board Oh raise or lower land
first oh that that's that's something I
didn't come up with this thing is slowly
but surely looking good but it sure is
taking a lot of time but then again I
need this thing to look good this is
going to be the masterpiece wouldn't
roller coaster off this park so it has
to be good you know I'm just going to
see if I can work some airtime Hills
into this area and then come up with
some other things to do like run
underneath this kind of section
yeah I think that is already better than
anything I've had before this I'm
definitely going to do that okay
no no no I got that over the way let's
make this a tiny bit higher although the
speed might not be too good over there
and let's make it lower than that
doesn't quite work let's see if I extend
this one out one bit there was a true
you know you know what never never mind
I'm going to give up on that I am
finally on the right track at least
that's why I feel like yeah I didn't I
didn't even make that one on purpose
I'm very sorry okay hmm though I'm not
too sure about having two diagonal
sections next to each other but you know
it could work if I actually do this
correctly and then we'll have like a yes
AGC I kind of small he'll like that
oh damn that is sexy it's even sexier
from this perspective even though it
wasn't made for that but damn it's
beautiful from over here but that is not
going to work though and that isn't I do
so
and that just looks strange definitely
don't want to add small parts that lower
the track like that Plus this looks
strange as a whole from over here no
it's cool and it looked good from over
here but I think it's something I'm
going to have to remove sadly say what
else will I do I need to find a way to
actually move this over here because
that looks a lot better that definitely
looks a lot better but the question is
how do I do that because this looks ugly
and if I'm going to make it one when
like h-hi oh I don't even know what you
call that in this game it's gonna be
very slow at that point now that's also
definitely something I want to avoid so
even though I feel like this would be my
best option it just doesn't look good
mmm okay so what if I add this and then
go back over there hopefully this is
going to make it if I love it but nope
nope that does not work no that's a
shame
I think I really do have to get it next
to the other part okay I'm going to try
something else I'm going to lower this
hill
and I'm going to see if it's possible to
at the curve over here we're just still
not possible what why just just give me
that curve in that case I'm going to
lower it even more and that's right it's
still not possible okay that doesn't
work at all it was not the height that
caused that curve to be impossible but
it was just that Trek over there
and oh wait I am 1h lower now let's see
if I can do this
oh that definitely I don't know how I
did that I have no idea how I did that
but it works alright okay that there we
go that is why I needed and now we're
gonna go down like that gonna have that
curve which is absolutely perfect I must
say and I'm gonna do some stuff over
here oh yeah that is that is absolutely
gorgeous that is beautiful
maybe I can run around it over here oh I
can hmm that is pretty cool and then I
can like do some stuff over here too
which is which is pretty awesome like
it's kind of stupid the way that it it's
all tangled and stuff but I do like the
look of it although the game doesn't
like to actually do it but you know
sometimes you just have to ignore them
what the game says and go for what you
want to go for still some problems over
there hmm
please let me do this though this is
this is awesome eh what did we just do
what why is this I add up Briggs what no
I have to wait until it's fixed now
nobody will want to get on the ride
because it's crushed and and I even had
a brakes where they were they it's still
too fast to total brake failure if it's
a total brake failure I'm going to kill
you strata less for telling me to add
brakes because otherwise my coaster
would crash because none of the coaster
Dutton the coasters that didn't have
brakes ever crashed but now I built one
that has brakes and lo and behold it
crashed mmm mmm I need to go back
but the question is how do I do that
yeah there's this clearly doesn't work
feel like I might want to try something
like this
and then go back in some way because the
issue with this is the more tangled your
coaster becomes the more hard it becomes
to actually finish it and that is
exactly the spot that I'm in right now
this is a mess
a beautiful mess though I have to say
that but it's a mess in on the least I'm
[ __ ] out okay let's see mmm no come
on
hmm there's bumper car music sure is
making me pumped though awesome music
mmm no that doesn't really look good I
think I feel like the thing that I just
had I think it was a 10 age was still my
best bet even though it doesn't really
want to work it might at some point the
only issue here is the available space
now I don't know whether there's
actually space available over here there
isn't clearly so that's right like this
I haven't even tried this yet oh and
that there's a roller coaster over there
too okay let's let's look at this I
can't do that even though it does look a
bit boring I can't do it but then again
it looks boring I'm going to try to run
it around this area and go underneath
the track over here which is clearly not
working no
I do want to keep this out this open
area over here not so open so that
doesn't seem like the best bet this
still feels like the best thing I can do
but it's such a strait kind of shape
well that's something I want to avoid
can i buy that land over there I can but
I'm not really sure if I'm going to do
it like this so I might want to look at
that later I kind of want to have a
diagonal track piece in this line over
here but getting there is pretty much
impossible at this point unless I do
that oh yeah that that might just
totally have done it there's much this
might do it okay let's see if I can get
back right there not yet
yes yes oh yes oh yes this is happening
I'm gonna buy this land and am I going
to buy more land I think so
I think I should probably can't buy the
any rights so I'm going to have to buy
the land if I want to go underground but
that's not necessary I can also go in
that direction maybe the roller coaster
even larger I sure hope that this thing
is actually going to make it because so
much work went into this and it would
truly be a shame if it actually didn't
work of course that is not going to
happen because I am certain that this
thing is going to work but you know it
would be a shame I'm just fantasizing
about that I need to raise or lower that
land that is also that is always going
to be lower
oh yes oh yes yes yes this is happening
up over here and I'm gonna go down there
so Rolo know that no it's not in the way
what are you talking about like that
then okay nothing's in the way we have
no problems with any rollercoasters
anything
however we are incredibly stuck at this
spot so see if we can move over there
which is pretty much impossible it the
the issue is this airtime Hill over here
it kind of seems unnecessary and it's
it's blocking what I should have over
there but making something like this
even though this would work and it would
be great
you know I I definitely want to avoid
that guys that's not good because you
have that one little thingy over here
which I want to avoid and what I could
also do is just go down like that but
now that didn't work hmm yeah this is
this is hard
hmm you know I you couldn't make a small
hill like that you could do that but
then again that's that's kind of awkward
and can I you know what I am just going
to do that no because that little hill
just solved all my problems I'm just
going to expect that the speed is not
going to be too bad over there and it
will be possible and now I can move back
to the station and yes this is happening
and I'm gonna have that that nine over
there and then we're gonna have the
brakes dude this is this is awesome this
is a pretty cool layout so breaks
because strata Liz wants them you can
get them even if they don't work right
into the state no wait no wait no no no
that's a bad idea
are we gonna have a small curve and then
we're going to go back to the station so
we have a larger station very good one
pond fish and I'm gonna place this thing
over there and get that nice little cue
line nice yellow cue line I must add and
move it like that oh this is going to be
hard let's see there we go and back to
the normal path and it's all finished
and now comes the big moment where
hopefully it is actually going to work
and not crash or be stuck anywhere
so hopefully this thing is going to work
I don't know what am I going to name
this this monster because this wooden
rollercoaster sure is a monster I I've
no idea for the name the colors however
I am certain are extremely terrible
right now different colors per train
because that's the usual kind of thing
for these things train one is going to
be that column a two is gonna be that
color kind of the vague colors that
you'd want to have on a winning roller
coaster and let's see if it actually
makes it I am seriously going to cry if
this doesn't make it because this was
purely built on experience and just kind
of
kind of experience of how fast these
things go but so far the speed is
excellent I have to say pretty good over
there but this is not the this is not
the problem area the problem area is
whether it's going to make these things
or whether it's not going to be too slow
in this area so let's see if it's if
it's actually going to make that all
right it has a respectable speed on that
point and same goes for this area it's
not too fast it's not too slow either
you know what I am really happy about
this and it's gonna go over there it's
gonna go down it's definitely not too
fast in those little hills and coming
back to the station with a perfect speed
that is [ __ ] amazing yes yes ok now
this thing is going to be called the I
don't know something that has to do with
the wood I can't come up with anything
so this is just going to be the no
that's a terrible idea
this is going to be the I don't know
anything about of wood or forests or
anything like that I could just come up
with a stereotypical wooden coaster name
there's gonna be the loop-de-loop you
know no that's an even person see this
is this is why I never spend time on
names because I am so incredibly
terrible at them wait was that I don't
get any thrill rides this is all the
thrill rides that I get oh I can bill a
top spin that's pretty cool but a lot of
time has passed since I built this thing
what's my Gore even for this bike 500
get ah I'm going to make that no problem
the issue is whether this coaster is
going to have a good name you know what
I am going to be that guy for once no
I'm not no I'm not gonna do that
no I'm not gonna say leave your leave
your name suggestions in the comment box
because now that has taken it too far
it's just the name for a simple roller
coaster doesn't matter too
much it's gonna be caught Bob Marley no
it's gonna be called Metallica yeah
that's going to be it mm-hmm and that is
the worst thing for a wooden roller
coaster ever
applause and now we're going to you have
some crunch rubbery around that would
you like some ground shrubbery with your
wooden roller coaster yes sure do need
plenty of that there is no such thing as
too much furniture Barry and now I'm
going to a ground shrubbery round
shrubbery and I'm going to place these
trees because I call Foresti trees and
I'd like to associate them with wooden
roller coasters oh wait I forgot I still
need to make that little area over there
look less shitty that's easily done by
doing this shrub is in the way you know
what screw that I'm sure I'm just going
to change the ground texture that's it
I'm lazy today how I'm even lazier I'm
just gonna text you a large section
there we go
and let's not bother with that anymore
I'd rather play some red FERS beautiful
no but seriously I really like this guy
oh that is a yeah bad idea I really like
this coaster which I almost sound
arrogant saying that but you know
sometimes it almost feels like you are
not truly to blame for your terrible
coasters or to praise for your amazing
coasters it almost feels like
determinism would really be a thing and
would actually count for creativity as
well but whatever regardless of that
sometimes you just build rollercoasters
and they come out so much better than
you ever imagined and you're just doing
random things and it just comes out
amazing and that's what this roller
coaster kind of looks like so there you
have that I'm going to kind of spice
this up a little bit though Chinese
sailors because those things are
beautiful
and some small Grunch rubbery there we
go
that is absolutely gorgeous I almost
feel like this this cook on TV doing
like they're like Jamie Oliver saying
how you can make pizza or something
instead of toppings though we have
crunch robbery in this game so Metallica
is pretty awesome the ratings are off
the charts I can ask 7 euros for this
[ __ ] do you even realize how much that
is like the kids in my high school
usually refer to money in terms of bags
of chips you can buy with it well you
can also eat crisps you can buy 14 of
those with this money so others just one
ride on one measly roller coaster in
measly leafy Lake Park but this thing
has to be opened there it is the grand
opening of Metallica so thank you for
watching and in the next episode I'm
just going to do some random stuff until
I finish this scenario which is in how
many months August September October
three months so that is perfect so I'll
see